vous me demandiez comment se comporter
et bien nous serons clair nous sommes
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron nous
restons dans l'opposition à emmanuel
macron comme l'a rappelé hier le conseil
stratégique grattements ça se traduit
par quoi une opposition systématique ou
une opposition constructive c'est pas la
même chose et le ministre clément boon
qui a une bonne formule qui dit les
français nous ont livré un meuble en kit
mais sans nous donner le mode d'emploi
est ce que demain à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le groupe parlementaire
des républicains qui va tenir le mode
d'emploi c'est vous qui avez des clés en
main ou pas de fait nous avons
aujourd'hui l'occasion de défendre nos
priorités mais nous le ferons encore une
fois dans la clarté moi je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient de mode d'emploi a inventé
la vérité de cette élection c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des députés
les républicains qui sont arrivés avec
un mandat clair sur un projet explicite
nous savons ce que nous avons proposé à
nos électeurs ce que nous défendons
auprès d'eux depuis des années
maintenant et donc tout ce qui ira
évidemment dans le sens que nous n'avons
cessé de défendre et il est évident que
nous le voterons cela a été fait aussi
au cours des dernières années si nous
avons enfin une réforme des retraites
courageuse comment votent aurions-nous
contre 2 jeux ça veut dire avec un âge
légal de départ à 65 ans c'est même pas
oui bien sûr mais mais en tous les cas
c'est même pas tellement le sujet le le
sujet c'est de dire que ce que nous
avons défendu c'est à dire l'idée qu'il
faut que la france se remette à
travailler pour produire ce dont elle a
besoin pour retrouver sa compétitivité
pour retrouver son rayonnement
économique dans le monde pourrait de
nouveau capable de reconquérir son
indépendance cette france qui est
aujourd'hui déficitaire commercialement
depuis des années ce qui nous permettra
de renouer avec le travail nous le
soutiendrons ce qui nous permettra de
valoriser le travail nous soutiendrons
mais c'est clair c'est pas d'accord de
législature mais des discussions au cas
par cas sur janot est stone roses et
sion mais nous restons dans l'opposition
et je crois qu'il faut redire à quel
point le président de la république a le
devoir d'entendre le message qui lui a
été envoyé par les français et pour moi
il s'agit pas seulement d'examiner texte
par texte ce qui doit être discutée et
ce qui devrait être voté il s'agit
d'abord de dire au président de la
république que le gouvernement qu'il
envoie devant le français a été
disqualifié par cette élection
législative il faut changer ce
gouvernement comment maintenir au
pouvoir il me semble que comment nous
nous pouvons comment nous pourrions
imaginer que soit maintenue aujourd'hui
leurs responsabilités des ministres qui
sont soit profondément discrédité soit
profondément controversé un mini un
ministre de l'intérieur qui de manière
évidente a menti sur une affaire qui
engage la crédibilité de la france
devant l'europe toute entière
comment peut-il comment peut-il rester
en poste cette élection est aussi le
signe
il me semble qu en tous les cas il ya
quelque chose qui doit être entendu dans
le message des français à l'occasion de
ce deuxième tour de l'élection
législative rose
[Musique]